Since we love fractions so much, let's just maximize our use of them. We have a
fraction on the left side, 6x minus 5 over the quantity 7 minus 3x. And we also
have one on the right, 4 minus 8x over the quantity 4x plus 2. We just saw how
effective it is to try to get rid of our denominators, that at least, leads us
to a point where we can start to manipulate this in ways that we can get x by
itself. But here, we have two denominators, we have one on the left and one on
the right. I'd still like us to get rid of them and we know that we do that
through multiplying by them. So in this box, I'd like you to write out the
entire equation you'll get at the very first stage, where you no longer have
fractions in this equation. So I don't want you to multiply anything out I don't
want you to distribute or simplify on either side. I just want you to get this
to a place where there are no more fractions.